a brief glimpse of one of the world's
most important processes kovat 19 tests
being analyzed in a lab this small
laboratory in Oxford normally handles
urinary tract samples now its owner
entrepreneur Mike Fisher has turned it
over to coronavirus tests we started
about a week ago and serious that when
we're up to a hundred tests a day using
a very conservative kit as we get more
proficient at the logistics we could
easily scale it up to 500 tests a day
the team sent us these pictures from the
closed room where they do the testing
putting samples into these specialized
polymerase chain reaction machines or
PCR there's been a lot of worry about
testing kits and chemicals for testing
but if you talk to medical researchers
they say that isn't the issue because
they can be mass-produced what can't be
a PCR machines and the people who can
operate them and that's why they have
been working at full capacity that
prospect just got a boost because mike
who founded stock photography company
Alami has given 1 million pounds to
support the idea some have high hopes
with 14,000 of these PCR machines which
in every university lapin if the
commercial lab in britain so I'm sure
we've got 14,000 of them I mean if the
people are already operating this
machine is doing other things turned
over to testing for the virus um you
could test everybody in Britain once a
week to ramp up testing for frontline
staff the government has requisitioned
PCR machines for its centralized lab the
death decay equivalent of a factor of
production line NHS bosses say the most
urgent requirement is getting that
system up to speed
anything is is going to help if it can
up the numbers even by a few hundred or
a few thousand a day that will be
immensely helpful but what I'm saying is
that this is a national problem that
also needs a national solution as
a number of smaller innovative solutions
to test the nation every contribution
will be needed from the very big to the
very small in the local louse they're
calling it the Dunkirk spirit a famous
rescue albeit from the jaws of defeat
Braham on top Sky News in Oxford